if we are sitting here trying to think
how do we make more money what's the
point of making more money if we're not
going to do anything with it the thing
that we do with the money that we make
is turn around and make better videos so
yeah if at any point we are like I said
we we have Ambitions in order to reach
those goals we do need to make more
money in order to be able to afford to
to attack those goals but it is very
much that making money is in order to
make videos for sure
hey friends welcome back to Deep dive
the ongoing podcast where every week I
get the chance to sit down with
inspiring authors entrepreneurs creators
and other inspiring people and we talk
about how they got to where they are and
the strategies and tools that we can
learn from them to help live our best
lives now this is very exciting because
this is an interview between me and
Marquez Brownlee Marcus Brownlee also
goes by the name MKBHD on the internet
and he's one of the world's largest tech
YouTubers he's been on the platform for
more than 10 years and has made hundreds
I think if not thousands of videos all
about tech and consumer Tech and his
channel is one of the most well
respected on the entire platform right
now Marquez has a whole team of 12
people around him he's got this enormous
Studio makes incredibly high quality
videos and so we talk a lot in the
discussion around this idea of being a
Creator in the modern Creator economy
how he grew as a YouTuber how he managed
to stay consistent for 10 plus years
producing Tech content week after week
month after month so I hope you enjoyed
this conversation with one of the
legends of YouTube as much as I did
let's let's roll the conversation
Marquez hey thank you so much for coming
on the show how are you doing today I'm
really good thanks for having me yeah
this is gonna be fun um so obviously
I've been following your channel for
like decades it feels at this point and
the place I wanted to start was that you
and you and iJustine are like in the
tech YouTuber space have been around for
such a long time and have managed to
stay consistent and seem to continue to
be having fun with the thing and I
remember you were on the Y combinator
podcast and they asked you something
around the lines of you know Marcus
what's the secret to your success and he
kind of shrugged and he said well if you
do anything for 10 years then you're
bound to be successful at the thing and
so the place I wanted to start was like
how have you managed to stay so
consistent in kind of basically doing
the same sort of stuff over the last 13
14 years and how have you made it fun
and kind of interesting for yourself as
you've evolved over time yeah wow that's
a really good question there's a lot of
a lot of smaller answers that add up to
a bigger thing so I feel like the the
number one thing is it's fun we enjoy it
I we're all nerds here at the studio I
enjoy Tech trying it trying a new piece
of tech every day is like what that's
like the dream it's super fun
um and genuinely having so many things
under my belt now that we feel
calibrated enough that I can turn around
and give my opinions on a piece of tech
and actually share it and have it be
valuable is super cool so it's just fun
to review Tech and show it to people
we're also video nerds so it's fun to
make videos and that's fun too and we
get we try to get better at it every
time
and then I think also probably a little
piece of that interview around that same
point was uh as a creator
you you see this sort of a lifespan of a
Creator right it's it's typically
relatively short as far as careers go
but luckily as a tech Creator or as a
product Focus Creator the pressure's not
on me to like keep it interesting or
keep it spicy or whatever it's it's
actually just up to the tech companies
and I'm just having fun following along
pointing the camera at the stuff and uh
and evaluating and reviewing and
checking it out so it's a sort of a nice
combination of all those things I think
that come together to just we just keep
making videos yeah yeah this was a big
part like when I when I started YouTube
about five years ago like this month
five years ago um I sort of had in the
back of my mind that the only people it
seems who have serious longevity on the
platform outside of like people like
PewDiePie although even even he was kind
of is younger in a vertical than than
you and iJustine are it seems like Tech
really does lend it lend itself to that
longer Arc of a career whereas the thing
that I worry about all the time is that
like will I still be relevant next year
will I be relevant the following year
what am I going to be doing do you have
any of those concerns at all around like
relevancy and like fading out of
people's minds and things like that
nicely I think no just because uh people
will always be somewhat interested in
the latest tech maybe it's not like oh
that the pro the position we're in now
is amazing where we're sort of at the
top of our game like people want to see
what I have to say about tech and
they'll go to it voluntarily which is
cool but I think the the second half of
that which is a nude piece of tech comes
out I'm gonna just point the camera at
it and see what I can reveal about it or
explore or review it or show it from the
owner's perspective people will always
be seeking that out and so even if I'm
you know not worried about being the
number one Tech reviewer in the world I
still feel like that will always exist
and I'll always have fun being a part of
that ecosystem
how how do you think if at all about
quote competitors like the other people
in the tech ecosystem in the tech sphere
you seem you seem to be friends with
like all of them but at the same time
you're also sort of competing in this
sort of committing sort of not like do
you worry about what they're doing do
you not really think about it how do you
approach that so far it's felt like a
rising tide lifts All Ships and I
genuinely mean that like when I look
back at Tech YouTube like seven eight
nine ten years ago all of us not only
were we all making worse videos but we
are all perceived differently we're all
taken less seriously
um at this point now uh it's sort of
matched maybe you'd consider traditional
media as far as respect levels and and
consideration as far as what you think
of a device and we're still trying to
improve on that but yeah we all we all
tend to to make each other better I'll
see things that other people are doing
in videos and I'm like oh that's cool
I'll talk to them about that I think
other people do the same thing with our
Channel I think there's a healthy amount
of like we're not really competing for
the same eyeballs because there's enough
to go around and that's also a good
thing about product videos on YouTube is
people want a variety idea of opinions
on things so yeah it doesn't really feel
like competitors as much as it's like a
community of it's an ecosystem I think I
used that word already but it's an
ecosystem
yeah no I think it's the same approach
for like you know my stuff is around
productivity and personal development
and stuff and people often ask that hey
how do you feel about the fact that
other people are doing kind of doing the
same thing and I always or I also use
that phrase like the rising tide lifts
all the boats
um if Matt dibella has a cold shower
video then it's likely to be suggesting
Nathaniel Drew's couple shower video and
so if I make a cold shower video and we
will do it in our own ways then actually
that's that's pretty cool and we're all
mates and it just feels like quite a
quite a fun thing especially when we can
meet in in real life I imagine you have
a similar similar kind of approach to
her yeah yeah and I feel I also think
there's uh there's a good amount of I
guess there's a there's a process for
trying to decide what we make videos on
and most of that process doesn't really
consider what other people are making
videos on luckily it's just what do we
think is cool and what do we think is
Worth showing and sharing maybe it's a
review maybe it's an explainer maybe
it's an interview maybe it's a dope Tech
video maybe it's this whatever we got
ideas and I think if there's other
people making cool videos then we can
take and we can take advice from that we
can we can collaborate with other
creators it's all sort of a net positive
on that note of like deciding what
videos to make how much are you good how
much does it play on your mind of oh I
know if I make this sort of video it'll
get this this many views versus more
like I feel like making this video
because I feel like it and sort of that
to me that's always felt like a bit of a
spectrum of like doing things because I
feel like it versus doing things because
I know they'll perform well
um how how do you think about sort of
videos along along that Spectrum if if
it even is a spectrum yeah so I think
this is super lucky that the videos that
I know will do well are the most
interesting to me also because they're
about probably a piece of tech that is
so cool that I want to check it out
anyway right so on one half it's like
what videos will do well it's uh the
hottest gadgets the most impressive new
things that people haven't seen before
uh collaborations with really cool
interesting people those I I know before
we make them are like oh those are going
to do pretty well and then on the other
half is what do I want to do and
sometimes it's well I want to check out
this gadget this seems pretty cool well
I kind of want to talk to this person
they seem really interesting to talk to
and suddenly like they're like meshing
together and it's kind of the same pool
of things so often um again it's like I
don't have that much pressure to to like
I don't really I'm not interested I'm
not into this video but I'm gonna do it
anyway because I know what it'll get a
lot of views that doesn't happen too
often for me because if I know it's
going to get a lot of views why is that
going to get a lot of views because it's
a really interesting piece of tech oh
okay so I'm in and has that always been
your attitude or was that a thing that
changed over time I think that's
something I figured out over time I know
that there are videos that I make that
aren't going to blow up like the ones
that are the most popular gadgets but I
still want to share them because I still
think they're cool and I think if I can
make the video in a way that actually
shows why I'm so interested in it then
it will eventually
be interesting to people and we'll catch
on so I think that's something I sort of
learned probably in the second half of
making videos which is that yeah we can
we can sort of justify pretty much any
video we want to make
nice
um one one thing that struck me about
your stuff is that you don't have a lot
of sponsored content it seems like it's
very occasional that you'll do you'll do
a sponsorship and you don't plug your
own merch very much either so I've just
been very very intrigued for a while
like what is the MKBHD business model
and it seems also on that point that
you're not really chasing Revenue
because you could make money more
efficiently or more effectively if you
wanted to I'm sure what is the business
model and what are the I guess the
metrics or the goals that you're
actually optimizing for because I
imagine it's not we just want to make as
much money as possible the overarching
goal behind everything
just to to keep in the back of my head
for all this stuff is we want to make
what we want to watch and that actually
it translates pretty well towards like
the entire business and if you keep that
in the back your head towards any part
of what we do it makes a lot of sense so
when we consider like what videos we're
gonna make it's what what would we want
to watch what we what would we it's like
a tongue twister what would we want to
subscribe to that's the type of Channel
we're trying to build and then as far as
Revenue like we are in a position where
the AdSense on the videos makes a good
amount and so we do very very carefully
hand select like we're extremely picky
about when we work with sponsors because
they all we also want them to make a lot
of sense you're right we could decide to
make a sponsor the amount of no's I say
in my inbox like we could make a
sponsored video every single video for
the rest of time and and that would be a
very different Channel you wouldn't want
to subscribe to that channel but we
could do it if we wanted to make a lot
of money
um but yeah there are some sponsors
where it's it's a win-win for everyone
we see that it's a cool product and we
want to share it anyway and now it's
worth working with them and the whole
thing works out great so yeah we we do
have goals as far as expansion and and
building not just a team but uh I sort
of have like this dream video studio in
mind on the horizon and that's not going
to be cheap so we got to get there
somehow
but yeah there is a there's very much a
hand-picked very picky element about
when we do sponsored stuff and when we
plug stuff just because it's what we'd
want to watch so it sounds like it's
very much sort of
craft first and business second I guess
you can correct me if I'm wrong but it
sounds like kind of the business exists
for the purpose of the craft rather than
the other way around and I guess this is
something that Casey said um we're at
the North summit in Dubai he was like a
lot of creators make videos to make
money but he makes money so that he can
make more videos and so the the making
of the videos is just the instrumental
intrinsic joy that he gets from his life
would you say that's the same for you
like how do you balance kind of craft
versus business again assuming that
there's a there's a spectrum between the
two yeah that's a hundred percent I had
never heard that quote but that's
exactly how the way we see it like if we
are sitting here trying to think how do
we make more money what's the point of
making more money if we're not going to
do anything with it the thing that we do
with the money that we make is turn
around and make better videos so yeah if
at any point we are like I said we we
have Ambitions and in order to reach
those goals we do need to make more
money in order to be able to afford to
to attack those goals but it is very
much that making money is in order to
make videos for sure I actually have no
idea where you're actually based but my
understanding is like somewhere near New
York I have a friend who just moved to
New York and he said that like oh my God
the rents here are super expensive like
it seems like you've got like
ridiculously wealthy people and you can
spend an unlimited amount of money on an
unlimited number of things how do you
personally think about like your I guess
lifestyle creep and the sort of managing
essentially managing your relationship
with money because it's it's a thing I I
like to speak to a lot of kind of
creators and entrepreneurs are about
because it seems like in every creators
and entrepreneur's life cycle there
comes a point where you decide I've
actually got enough and I don't need to
optimize for money anymore whereas when
you're struggling to pay the bills
obviously you know at that point money
makes a lot of sense so there's a
certain point where enough is enough
yeah and some people say that if you're
living in the middle of like Utah there
actually isn't a way to spend large
amounts of money but when you're in New
York Suddenly It's like there's a lot
you could be doing I'm very curious how
how do you approach that relationship
between money and lifestyle yeah I so we
are we're in New Jersey we're right
across the river you can see New York
from our window so it's right there uh
we can get there quickly but it is much
cheaper to be in New Jersey than in New
York so price per square foot wise doing
pretty good over here
um no I think what's funny is I I was
I've been making videos forever and I
think uh when I was in college I went to
a school called Stevens Tech which is in
Hoboken New Jersey it's a technical
school and one of the things that
happens when you go to a school like
that is pretty much every student there
especially in my major the business
majors engineering Majors uh takes a
sort of structured quote the way they
build their college career is around
going to class and then going to intern
at a company they hope to work for and
then going back to class and so you have
these sort of periods that are
designated for that
and I went through my freshman year I
changed my major halfway through I
settled on this business with a
background in Tech and I finally got to
the point where the question was all
right you've made it through the first
year where do you want to go intern
like where do you want to work when you
finish this major where you should get
ahead of the the process and and go
intern somewhere in the city
and it was pretty much at that exact
moment that I realized I just want to
make videos that's that's all I want to
do so I didn't go intern anywhere I just
went back and made more videos and then
got back to class and then that was the
thing that I did with my time
and it turned out that that financially
made a lot of sense it when I dedicated
myself full-time to videos it was even
better for the channel then I went back
to class and I was like oh I'm spending
so much time on homework and I could be
I could be making videos again so yeah
it turned out I I didn't I didn't really
have too much second thought when I
graduated about what I was going to do
uh the channel was making enough money
that I didn't have to optimize for money
as you put it so that's what I started
to do straight out of college
and I think lifestyle creep is pretty
easy in a big city big fashion big you
know Big Apple all this stuff I don't
really spend that much money on
almost anything I don't I mean I wear I
wear t-shirts and jerseys like sneakers
maybe maybe that's my guilty pleasure I
don't I don't find that uh lifestyle
creep actually has too much of an effect
on the business or the or the stuff that
we do so luckily that's uh it's all
still true just a quick message from one
of our sponsors and we'll get right back
to the episode this episode is brought
to you by short form the world's best
service that summarizes books uh trust
me I've used all of them I'm not allowed
to mention them by name probably but
short form is by far the best one out of
all of them they even have summaries of
enormous books like Tim ferriss's tools
of Titans honestly I haven't I I've read
bits of this book but I've not yet
gotten around to reading all of it but
the short form summary takes all the
best ideas and puts it into a more
digestible summary than this enormous
beer myth of the book but it's way more
than just book summaries on short form
they also have these little segments
where you can engage critically with the
ideas with interactive exercises and
bits like that and whenever the author
says something or in this case the
various people that are interviewed in
the book say something controversial
then short form Flags it up and says oh
hang on this thing that Tim Ferriss
writes over here has actually been
completely debunked and disagreed with
by this person over there if he's
written that book and it just helps you
engage with the ideas on a way more
critical level then at least for me I
would have done otherwise for me
personally the two ways I use short form
is firstly I use short form if I'm
thinking of reading a book then I will
often instead of reading the whole book
cover the cover I'll read the short form
summary and then be like do I want to
actually read this book based on how
valuable or insightful or interesting I
found the summary and secondly once I've
already read a book short form is great
for revisiting the ideas in that book so
I don't have to reread the whole thing
and it tends to save me a lot of time
along with looking at my Kindle
highlights so if any of that sounds up
you're straight and you too want to
subscribe to the world's single best
service that summarizes books then head
over to shortform.com forward slash deep
dive and that link which is also in the
show notes and in the video description
is going to give you 20 a whole 20 off
the annual premium subscription so thank
you so much short form for sponsoring
this episode and I feel like this is
more of a thing in the US where you can
just creep up it seems way more than
than you can in the UK do you have I
mean without any without naming any
names
people that you know creators
entrepreneurs those those sorts of
people because I imagine you've come
into contact with some pretty wealthy
people you know Elon Musk aside have you
seen any of those sorts of people be a
cautionary tale for this sort of thing
at all not really I mean so a lot of the
creators I hang out with a lot of with a
lot of creators and I'm always
fascinated by their like their process
and the behind the scenes and also kind
of like the vibe of of what's Happening
like I you know there's creators that
are that are close to solo who you would
never imagine like still edit all their
own stuff there are creators who are
they feel like they're in a cog in the
machine they have a hundred employees
and there's just a bunch going on so I'm
always paying attention to that
and I I think they've all been pretty
positive examples
um in event in various ways I think
there's there's things to Aspire to and
a lot of the the creators I've had the
opportunity to talk to so I don't know
if there's any cautionary tariffs but I
know what you're talking about which is
like you know there's YouTubers who are
just like oh I finally made enough to
get uh this couple cars that I always
wanted now I'm gonna get the cars and
now what
I don't know
if you're I mean I I guess I'm lucky
that my hobbies are exactly what the
business is already doing uh I play I
play a sport it's not particularly
expensive to play other than traveling I
I golf sometimes that can be expensive
but I don't play enough for it to be
expensive
yeah so I guess I'm I'm pretty pretty
set
um on that note so if I think of
comparing like like for example the way
Linus runs his business versus you
versus I guess someone like Justine who
seems to be more of like a solo operator
with maybe a smaller team have you ever
considered going down the sort of Linus
Media Group 17 videos a week multiple
channels multiple hosts kind of thing
um and like how how do you think about
what you actually want from the channel
and from the business in the future yeah
for sure I I definitely still use the
back of the head what would I want to
watch what would I want to subscribe to
mentality as of right now I think I
probably subscribed to about I think
it's like 120 channels on YouTube
something like that if I subscribe to a
channel that uploads every single day I
better really like that Channel or I'm
gonna stop watching after a while I'll
get fatigued then I'll probably either
unsubscribe or not watch most of the
stuff so going down that like content
Factory Route is very much an
optimization for making money and
revenue which we don't need to do we
still have the mentality of okay what
would be a good video what do we
actually want to make or show or
accomplish with this video instead of
just we need a new video
that's that's where I'm at so I think
I'm probably if you're if you're making
a spectrum between
you know Justine and Linus I'm probably
closer to the Justine we have a team
here out of necessity that is extremely
talented and skilled and helps us make
really good stuff but it's not to make
more stuff or to make more money it's
not like an assembly line where we just
like cranking out the next thing it
works for some people but it also seems
like uh you're just hopping on a
treadmill and just turning up the speed
when did you start hiring people and I
guess like what what does the org chart
look like now and how's that sort of
evolved evolved over time yeah so I
remember first time technically hiring
someone was a former teammate of mine
Andrew he he currently runs the studio
here but it was like uh it was a CES I
remember one year and CES is always one
of those weird stressful times as a tech
Creator because there's so much stuff
you could maybe make a video about
but good luck getting to all of it so I
I remember after I finished a CES
just like sitting in the hotel with like
half the footage I wanted to have just
like wow I could use a second second set
of hands there like that would have been
way easier if I had somebody told the
camera and to like help me out with
things uh so he was the first person I
hired at this point the org chart is I
think we probably have a I don't
remember the exact number but I'll
figure it out as I count so Andrew runs
a studio with me so that's two
um we have the the main Channel videos
which are Vin and Brandon do
cinematography set design art design the
intros their camera work camera work is
awesome
so that's for
um we have an editor we have a sales ad
manager we have a behind the scenes
Channel
point point guard I guess runs it edits
it shoots it everything the studio
Channel then we have a podcast audio
editor and a podcast video editor and
then we have a Motion Graphics and a
still graphics and so that's 11 and
that's that's the sort of
I don't know if there's a flow to it or
it's sort of a blob at this point but
everyone has a designated task because
I've have you heard my octopus analogy
before yes I have I was going to ask you
about that next but I would love it if
you could elaborate on that yeah well
that's so okay so the octopus analogy is
like as you start off as a Creator
you're a solo Creator there are all
these different things that you do that
you really want to be good at but you
you have a main focus so for me it was
like I want to review Tech I want to
talk about tech but I also have to be a
professional cameraman and I have to be
a professional video editor and lighter
and I have to be a professional inbox
manager and and Finance and Accounting
and taxes and I also have to do all this
other behind the scenes stuff and audio
and and the list goes on and so you feel
like an octopus you've got eight arms
they're all doing different things in
order to stay on track at this point the
team we've built is all of the arms that
I've cut off so they're all much better
than I am at holding a camera they're
much better than I am at set design
they're much better than I am at sound
design at still Graphics so the
thumbnails are all better the the sound
is all better everything is better about
everything we make because of the team
and that is the purpose of the team so
yeah we I guess the the awkward ending
of the analogy is an octopus has three
hearts so I feel like as one of the
hearts I'm the beating heart I am still
very much like talking Tech reviewing
Tech you know content strategy but the
team is now built out around it in a way
that it is is pretty smooth yeah I think
it's it's kind of the same for me so we
have a team of 13 of which like nine ish
are like in person but a big chunk of
that is running operations for the
courses that we do and then there's like
a much smaller team because the soldiers
the sort of videos that I do don't have
such a kind of heavy lift in terms of
production and cinematography uh it
would be awesome if they did but
um I think my vibe is more like what do
I want to be doing basically just like
exploring cool Concepts and talking to
the camera about them and similarly I
don't really want to have to be doing
the editing and so that was something
that I outsourced early on I was
listening to another interview with you
from a few years ago where you said you
were still holding onto the editing uh
are you are you still doing the editing
yourself or have you have you cut off
that particular arm yet we're slowly
adding that so we have a new editor and
we're sort of working on matching style
adding you know what they should edit
versus what I should edit I still edit
most stuff that you end up seeing but
the studio Channel I don't edit the
podcast channels I don't edit so it
depends on what you're watching but yeah
we do we do cut that arm off pretty soon
what's been what's been the biggest
surprise around having your own team or
the biggest challenge that you hadn't
quite realized would be a thing as you
as you built up over time oh that's easy
uh you become you have to add an arm
which is managing people that's a that's
a whole new a whole new job so yeah
before my job was find the tech that's
worth making a video about make the
video find out what makes a good video
like all that is very much a front of
Mind Focus but as you become the Hub of
the wheel you also need to sort of
manage and optimize everyone's processes
towards making that video where before
you controlled everything now you have
to sort of control the control uh so
that was my my biggest surprise I'm I'm
learning at it I'm getting better at it
I think that's a learned skill but yeah
that's that's for sure like a new amount
of time that I have to be prepared to
spend
so are you the one like for example
doing one-on-ones with all other 10 team
members or like is it that you have a I
guess general manager who does all the
day-to-day management like I'm so
curious to dig into sort of how the
business operates like within within the
machine that you've got sure it kind of
feels like pretty much everything has to
go past me in order to be published like
content-wise
um but as far as like running things you
know Andrew and I sort of tag team like
running the studio and assigning things
and make sure everyone's doing the thing
that needs to get done that's kind of it
I feel like there's only maybe two
levels to it I guess as far as org chart
like visuals but I think that helps I
think the team's not too big that it's
like we need like a manager to to manage
a group within a group that has a
manager to manage the managers or
anything like that that's that's a lot
we just have our our creative team and
our business team and they all sort of
work together yeah yeah at one point we
had a team that was approaching the size
of like 20 and at the size of 20 we had
to have like middle managers whose only
job was to manage the people doing the
thing and we ended up having like a
bunch of issues around like
communication and stuff and so as we
sort of head down to working with people
more part-time in Freelancers it really
felt as if oh okay now we have a Content
team and now we have a courses team and
those those are like the two helps of
the business that work well together
what does your process look like from I
guess idea to video being published what
are the steps along the way with the
people that sort of get involved with
making an idea come to life yeah so
let's go with uh let's go with a classic
video a reviewing a phone yeah right so
Step One is the phone arrives at the
studio and I take it out the box
sometimes I'll shoot the unboxing if I
know that's going to be part of the
video and I put my SIM card in it I set
it up and I start using it and I start
testing it we have a so I actually
mentioned I forgot one of them earlier a
writer researcher script supervisor
David will help me with a lot of the
research and making sure we've got all
the points worth mentioning about this
device about this phone all in one dock
so I'm taking notes as I'm using it
we're brain dumping into this document
and then eventually we get to the point
where we're like all right I think we've
got it I think we've got everything
let's turn it into a script a story a
through line something that's worth
watching that's basically my job is to
to translate all of this information
into the headline the thumbnail the
thing that will live on YouTube
then we shoot the thing so there's sort
of two versions I'm sure you do this too
there's a roll and b-roll so you shoot
your a-roll where you're talking to the
camera and then you have pieces where
you know you're going to be you know
you're talking but you also have like
footage ready for when you're gonna talk
about that stuff we typically start with
shooting a-roll so that I have all of
the talking out of the way and then we
know all the little quirks and things
that I've mentioned and then we will go
shoot all of the rest of the b-roll to
cover all the things we need a lot of
that is Venom Brandon shooting b-roll
off on their own a lot of that is I've
got a couple shots in mind I need I'll
I'll grab them and go up to the roof and
we'll go shoot some stuff that I know we
need to get we cover the whole script
everyone has access to the script then
it gets edited for the most part that's
just me ingesting all the footage and
Landing it down on the timeline and then
if there is any sort of extra fancy
visuals then we'll go sort of Next Level
say this one as a robot shot in the
intro I'll be editing the main video
while Andrew Vin and Brandon will go off
to the robot studio and will make their
incredible Masterpiece and then that can
tie in back to what I've been editing so
they'll give me a couple ideas we'll
pick one we'll go this is one that would
really work with the YouTube tagline and
sort of you can see the Whirlwind
happening as the content gets made it
gets to the end of the process I finish
the video we give it one last walk
through the whole timeline watch the
whole video together any last
adjustments okay it's good export upload
publish nice
what what prompted you to spend such an
ungodly amount of money on a robot
Studio
what's uh what's the top process behind
that there is actually several things
and I think it makes a lot of sense now
that all those things are real so number
one we went out and shot a dope Tech
video at that studio company that makes
them had no intention of getting one
when I went out there but they came to
us with the idea hey check it out we do
these camera robots I was like that is
so sick let me check it out we go out
there we shoot with them they get some
example shots or whatever we come home
within a day of getting home I was like
I wonder if we should get one of those
things that was kind of cool
um but the other thing about it is look
there's a thousand different Tech videos
that you can watch now about the new
iPhone SC that just came out right why
would you watch mine maybe just because
it's me some people will watch it just
because it's me but I want to give you
like a real tangible reason to watch
this one because you have so many
options and so we start to do things
like cool shots in the videos realistic
shots in the videos extra depth and
insight in the research and testing but
one of the things that we found is
anything that you do at this level at
the highest level ideally is very
visible and lots of people will try to
copy it and all I wanted was something
that's really hard to copy so if we do
stuff like top down shots and everyone
else is doing top down shots all of a
sudden great if we do stuff like macro
shots of certain things and then
suddenly those show up fine they're
they're good ideas of course people will
take them that's the whole point but we
wanted a couple things that we could do
that are unique to our videos to give
you a reason to watch them and also
everyone here at the studio is a video
nerd and when I had the idea of maybe
getting the video robot it was pretty
unanimously hell yeah let's do it and so
all that stuff sort of came together and
now we have a robot yeah I find that
like when I when I see a
when I see a Marcus Brownlee video I am
just like oh I wonder what they're gonna
do in the intro this time and I'll often
just sort of re-watch the intro and I'll
be like I think the latest one with the
pixel 4A or pixel 6A you sort of took it
away from the thing I was like Oh that's
oh no oh that's kind of a nice nice one
there and just like watched that a few
times and yeah it's it's become this
sort of I imagine you get this feedback
a lot from people become this sort of
Easter egg where I'm like oh yes let's
see what's going on what's going to
happen this time around and I guess
that's kind of fun for you guys being
video nerds as well it's fun yeah
exactly we we enjoyed making the videos
and also we enjoy like having the the
sort of Easter egg moment of the fact
that it relates to it's not just a cool
shot like we could just do a cool shot
but this shot will actually have some
sort of reference to the video itself or
a reference to the to the title or the
headline or something that we're gonna
say in the video and so that extra
challenge of making it really intrinsic
to the video is probably why people
enjoy that extra level of like watching
the intro and then getting into the
video yeah
um what was the I guess what happened
during covid when it wasn't like uh
people in the studio in real life
anymore situation I'm imagining like
what was working in that kind of setup
like that was a absolute nightmare
so I am the type of YouTuber that is
terrified that if I give something up
I'll forget how to do it well
so as I've slowly started to add pieces
of the team I will still occasionally
chip in and do the thing like like Tim
makes 9 out of every 10 thumbnails but
I'll still make one out of every 10.
like I'll edit these things
um and during covet everyone had to
leave I think we had at that point five
people
and it was at the exact moment that we
were moving Studios so we had all of our
stuff upstairs in this building and we
basically got kicked out it was right
around the start of a new month where
we'd switched our contract down to this
place down here so by myself basically I
became a furniture moving machine I
found a way to drag thousands of pounds
of furniture down into the elevator and
across this building into the new studio
uh spent a couple weeks doing that set
some things up and then you know a
couple months go by people start
becoming more comfortable coming back
vaccines are a thing and I am very
grateful for the team coming back
because we can make much better stuff
when they're here you can probably see a
shift in like the second half of 2020
where the videos were like very like OG
YouTube and then they went back to being
like like a little bit above you know
the classic production level that's uh
that's the team just a quick little
break to tell you all about the sponsor
of this episode which very excitingly is
Shopify Shopify is sick it's like the
best platform in the world for starting
and growing an online business because
it is like an e-commerce and an
in-person way of selling stuff on the
internet or in person taking basically
any payment method selling in basically
any country and obviously building an
online business requires you to sell
stuff and Shopify is by far the easiest
way to sell anything on the internet
we've been using Shopify for over a year
now to host essentially which is my
stationary line so Shopify hooks up with
our warehouse provider and our Logistics
provider they've got thousands of other
Integrations as well so it's super easy
to get your Shopify store connected to
stuff which is exactly what we've done
and we're also in the process of
building out our own Shopify store where
we're going to be selling digital
products including website themes and
notion templates and also where we're
going to be selling our online courses
and a bunch of other cool stuff further
down the line Shopify is super easy to
get started with you don't need to know
how to code at all you don't even need
to know how to design in fact the
template we use for our store is just
one of the templates you can get on
Shopify and all we had to do was tweak
it a little bit to make it look the
Elliott Bell Vibe and we didn't have to
do any kind of faff that it takes to set
up any other providers for e-commerce
where you have to know how to design you
have to know how to code it's just super
easy with Shopify it's not just tiny
stores like mine that run on Shopify
gymshark incredibly huge brand on the
runs off Shopify tons of other
absolutely huge Brands run on Shopify as
well so it's great if you're at the
level where you're scaling to sort of
multiple tens if not hundreds of
millions of dollars in sales as well but
if you're like me and you want to start
your online business you want to grow it
you want to have the tools you want it
to be nice and easy then head over to
shopify.com forward slash Ali abdall and
you can try out the free trial try it
out completely for free and if you like
it you can stick with it as we've been
doing for the last year so thank you so
much Shopify for sponsoring this episode
one thing I've I've done over the last
year is is think sort of like you know
what is the sort of YouTube channel that
I want to have what's the sort of
business I want to run and I kind of
realize that it's a lot more energizing
to work with people in person rather
than remotely and and I realized oh I
guess I could just hire people in person
and have a studio and hence why hence
why we're here but I will occasionally
see other kind of startups and stuff
where they've got a fully remote
Workforce and
and I was speaking to another YouTuber
friend a few days ago and he was saying
that hey man if you had a remote team
you'd be able to I don't know get people
from abroad and pay them less money and
not worry about benefits and you'll just
be on Zoom calls and there was part of
me that was like yeah I could but it's
just way more fun just hanging out with
people in real life what's what's been
your experience of sort of the I guess
creative collaboration IRL versus this
is over Zoom I've yeah I've definitely
found it much more engaging everyone
except one person Works in this in the
studio that one person being well they
were going to consider moving right at
the beginning of the pandemic so that
sort of got derailed but yeah it's it's
because so many pieces of the team work
together in so many different
spontaneous ways it makes sense to just
all be in the same room like we'll have
I'll have an idea and I'll just roll my
chair over to Tim and be like hey I just
airdropped you this this file Let's uh
let's do a couple of these edits and I
think it might be a thumbnail candidate
and then
you know David will roll back his chair
over to Adam and be like for the next
episode of the podcast I just had an
idea we were just editing this thing an
hour ago and I just wanted to just drop
this on your plate so you know about it
and so there's this and you know
everyone's collaborating and talking and
that sort of creative environment I
imagine is more productive than having
to do a zoom call every time it feels
like it's more productive
um so productive creative collaborative
everyone is a little more likely to take
action when it involves another person
rather than just sort of Zoom calls yeah
yeah I know I can I completely agree
like I feel like the uh the IRL thing is
where you get those serendipitous
connections that you know we found that
when some of our team was in person and
some of them were remote it's like we'd
be having an idea and then to to update
the person who was remote it would be
like oh now we have to arrange a zoom
call with that person which means oh now
we've got to play calendar Tetris and it
just adds so much friction that it's
like that person's never going to find
out about the idea and then the idea is
not going to happen because the people
who need to know about it are not going
to know about it and all that kind of
stuff we've been in this studio now for
the last almost like nine ten months and
we've got another two months in here and
so the next question is like where are
we moving to and so we've been scouting
out a few other places in London and for
me at this stage it's it feels like
there's a bit of a choice of like we
could downsize and I could try and film
back in my own apartment in my flat and
maybe the team would come occasionally
or we'd sign up to a wework or we could
actually get a studio for another year
and have a nice space where we can film
videos and podcasts and it's great Vibes
because the team's around but that
that's more expensive and what's in my
mind is like it's in our case if for
example the business was absolutely
loaded with cash it would it would be a
no-brainer just like oh let's go for the
studio because it's fun but in my mind
there's a bit of a concern around the
ROI of is it really worth spending all
this money for this extra space and just
being able to have slightly nicer shots
and slightly nicer Vibes uh what's
what's been your take on the whole Roi
of the studio is it Roi positive or in
in terms of money or do you not really
think of it in those terms that's an
interesting question
um I think at the highest level we we
don't have too many Roi concerns because
we sh we get so much use out of
everything that we do
um anything that we might do for one
single video it's more of like a Time
Roi than like a like a money investment
Roi type thing the the robot you know it
was very expensive but we've used it for
literally years now
I'm not too worried about Roi like the
studio is the single most expensive
thing that I regularly other than taxes
I guess pay but we shoot everything here
so yeah that's pretty Roi positive and
so yeah individual videos we might have
a hefty amount of time dumped into like
a 12 second clip where we're like we
gotta redo this robot shot we gotta redo
the animations here we got to get this
right that you know that's again on the
end of like we want it to be hard to
replicate so this is this is the goal
let's accomplish it but you know as far
as the studio goes I feel like YouTube
is a very visual medium and so if your
goal is to be more cinematic then the
studio can help you accomplish that if
the goal for the vibe is to feel more
like a home or like a small set or like
a less of a production which is a goal
for a lot of Productions is to feel like
less of a production then it makes more
sense to just go straight to that
um we kind of have a the way we've built
out the studio is like it's a large
space but with with a bunch of smaller
spaces in it that we can make feel more
homey or more reasonable than relatively
unrelatable 7000 square foot white box
so that's that's what we do that's the
goal so it would depend on what your
goal is if you specifically want the
videos to feel or look a certain way
then you sort of have to lean towards
that to accomplish it yeah I like how
like other than when you do like a
studio tour or in the studio YouTube
channel
you don't really get the impression that
you're shooting in a seven thousand
square foot place that has like you know
a whole team in it and like it it almost
does feel as if oh you're just shooting
in like a room and there's a Shelf at
the back and there's like a blue iMac
that says a on it and there's like a
little Easter egg of like little Android
roboty stick figure p in the background
and it it does kind of feel sort of OG
YouTuber of like I'm just shooting in my
bedroom but like obviously like a level
up and then you see the b-roll you're
like wait a minute what's going on here
um I imagine that's an intentional
decision on your part yeah yeah there is
uh so there's this very specific
aesthetic to the videos that I think a
lot of people don't really talk about
which is that they feel first person
instead of third person and I don't know
if that's the right terminology for it
but basically sometimes we'll we'll do
like a setup
and I'll go hey all right Vin and
Brandon we're gonna make a video with
the pixel 6A and uh any sort of Easter
eggs that you see in the script that you
think would work here let's build it
and we'll we'll build a set and then
we'll we'll have the camera like five
feet away from me and it'll look
incredible like a beautiful set and you
look at the frame and you're like I look
like someone is shooting a video of me
not like I am making a video
and it's just it's a very small visual
cue but you bring the camera way closer
in and you give it the wide angle and a
lot of times I'll even start you know
touching the camera like I'm right in
front of the camera I think that first
person feel is very intangible but very
important to the feel of the video that
goes for our set design for the fact
that we shoot in Corners more often than
we shoot against a blank white wall like
we're thinking a lot about that feel
just as much as the things that are
going into the video itself
um and I think that's the reason why it
never feels like we're shooting in a
giant white concrete box it's more we've
built things inside of the box to
accomplish a different vibe and sounds
like it's working pretty well yeah yeah
definitely I've never quite thought of
it in those in those ways but I I do
notice in your videos you know there are
sometimes when you're when you're
holding up a camera and you're looking
off to the side in the monitor to be
like is this in focus and part of me is
thinking that like surely you've got a
camera man behind you so you don't need
to do that but also it looks good
because it looks as if you're kind of
that Marcus Brownlee who was like Hey
guys 100 videos 73 subscribers it's just
like slightly leveled up rather than
like ridiculously leveled up with the
whole 7000 square foot Place yeah and we
don't actually so I mean sometimes
there's a cameraman but if I'm doing
a-roll like the camera's on a tripod
I've I've gotten so comfortable talking
to a camera on a tripod that's all it
ever is there's no person behind the
camera it's just me the tripod and the
monitor is right next to the camera so
that's kind of what it is it there are
you know there's things like
teleprompters that would theoretically
make the production better that I can't
see myself ever using because they feel
less natural I guess I haven't explained
I I write the video out in a dock and
then I have the dock on my phone and I
put the phone in my lap or on a table
next to me so when I talk to the camera
I'll pick up the phone read the first
two paragraphs put it down internalize
it and then just deliver it and it's not
going to be item to what I wrote down
but as long as I hit all the points that
I wrote down then I I've got the flow
going and then I'll pick it up read the
next couple put it down deliver them and
then sort of work my way through that
way so that's why sometimes I'll
go off on a tangent or like mispronounce
something or Miss say something because
I'm just sort of going through what I
want to tell you as if I'm talking to a
person and so I'm definitely guilty of
like having some mistakes in videos but
I think that all sort of
comes back to just the feel yeah of the
video it's very real yeah so on that
note something I spoke to
um Mr who's the boss about who I know is
a friend of yours who are in interviewed
on the podcast a few months ago uh he
said that he is very kind of
anal about the analytics and the
retention and making sure every single
moment is scripted and spends 100 hours
scripting and repeats a line like a
dozen times just to really try and
squeeze those extra points of retention
out of it and there was part of me that
was thinking oh wow that's like an
incredible attention to detail but
another part of me was that was thinking
wow that seems like a lot of work and I
I kind of get a bit stressed out when I
look at analytics and retention curves
and I don't really like looking at them
what's your relationship with analytics
and retention curves and trying to make
the video as retention heavy as possible
versus like being a bit more chill about
it how do you think about that here's
how I'll rephrase this do you watch any
sports
um I watch the occasional squash match
and occasional clips of you on Ultimate
Frisbee when I see them as b-roll but
yeah okay how many is it I'll try I
don't know any squash players so I use a
basketball example so how do you know
somebody is a good basketball player
number of
points scored in a season or just yeah
you can you can use points sometimes so
so you watch them you watch a game and
you get the sense as the game is going
on you're watching it like oh this guy's
this guy's the best player on the team I
mean he's got the most points I see him
dunking on people he's grabbing rebounds
over the top of people he's really
flashy with the ball like I can tell I
can tell this guy's good I really like
this this one player now if you wanted
to craft the best player let's say you
were just designing a player from head
to toe you could design it entirely
around stats he will have the most
points the most rebounds the highest
efficiency I'm going to look at all the
numbers and the curves and I'm going to
design the player that is the best and
statistically sometimes that player wins
MVP but sometimes it's just
the eye test sometimes is just a certain
look or a certain change in a historic
way that the game is played and that can
be just as valuable to a video even if
it doesn't match the the retention curve
or the stats or anything like that I
think you can have a healthy amount of
both
so to sort of bring it back to to
YouTube it's like I could obsess over
the numbers and sort of focus every
ounce of my my you know attention on
maximizing the numbers on paper and
theoretically that means it's a good
video because people made it to the end
and I successfully maximized retention
but I'm not that's not my only focus and
I think if it is my only focus I might
lose a little bit of the rest of what
makes a good video
so yeah the numbers we pay attention to
them I think they're sort of a guiding
force they're the bumpers on the bowling
lane more than they are the bowling ball
itself you know does that make any sense
uh yeah we pay attention to them but we
don't live by him speaking of numbers uh
in at the end of last year you tweeted
the following
um but seriously the only way to
guarantee meaningful positive change in
the next 365 days around the Sun is to
exit your comfort zone and relentlessly
attack your goals that's my plan anyway
good luck and happy New Year
um and I read that at the time I was
like okay I I wanna
understand your relationship with goals
in Aaron's case uh it's very numerical
like I know I want to hit 10 million
subscribers this year and I'm going to
try and reverse engineer the numbers to
hit the goal he's obviously stupidly
successful um in my case it's a bit more
like ah I don't really I don't really
like numbers I kind of like goals that
are under my control like hey I want to
make a video every week and once it's
out in the world Beyond tweaking a title
into thumbnail occasionally if it bombs
like there's not a lot I can do about it
so I'll not I'll try not to think about
it
um how do you approach goals and when
you say relentlessly attack your goals
what is what does that look like for you
yeah I think stepping out of the comfort
zone has been a big thing especially
with like adding the team that's been a
thing like I'm a relatively quiet
introverted person so building a team
around me is like a new outside of my
comfort zone thing
um but the goals really are pretty
simple and I'm like you I like to keep
them in our control so the goal is more
better
and I've I've mentioned this before like
if you try to do more of something you
probably do it worse and if you try to
do better at something you probably do
it less often so the fact that we have
built a team skilled and talented enough
that we can do more things and all of
them are better than they usually would
be that's a success for us numerically I
just kind of want to keep it on a study
positive I it's not really in my control
how people respond this the channel is
Pretty spiky I don't know if you you
look into analytics enough to know like
there's some channels that you know are
pretty steady growing or that are pretty
flat or that are you know sort of spiky
like mine
um sometimes there's just a device that
you don't expect that just people it
just clicks so people wanted to know
about it and you got the video out at
the right time great
um but that's not in my control so as
long as it's still on a general positive
I'm pretty happy
um but it is fascinating to see people
like set very specific goals that are
clearly not in their control but to
attempt to guide all factors towards
accomplishing it like like saying like
if I decided today all right we have a
certain subscriber count we want to hit
20 million subscribers by the end of
2024.
how on Earth would I guarantee that I
really don't know but I think doing more
and better would get us closer to it
that's kind of that's kind of all I can
control
and when you say that you had this
vision for like a dream a dream Studio
what is what does that look like and is
that the sort of thing that you're then
sort of reverse engineering based on
based on the vision how do you approach
that oh yeah well so we I I picture the
dream video studio and we already have
gotten quite a quite quite far as far as
this Vision like our current video
studio is kind of amazing we'll have
other Productions come in and they look
around they're like
you you guys own these RED cameras do
you you just you just have a Russian arm
in your parking lot like what I don't
understand because most of the time if
you want to put a good production
together you need to get the logistics
out you need to go all right here's the
cameras we'll need here's the set we'll
build if you if we walk into the studio
and I wake up with a good video idea we
can leave the studio that day having
finished the video because we just walk
up to the camera and it's right there
the equipment's right there the ability
to make something amazing we have the
robot room right here the editing is
right here everything is here so we can
just make whatever we want which is
amazing
um we're I sort of picture a leveled up
version of that that is a little bit
more
of just a little bit more of the the
right sorts of tools available to us at
any time and maybe a little bit more
organized than it is now because we sort
of just crammed a ton of stuff in here
that's one thing you don't see in the
videos is just how much stuff is just
everywhere in here so yeah we're working
on that it's going to take a little
while but we'll get there how so at the
moment you're 7 000 square feet like how
big do you imagine the dream Studio to
be we have been doing all kinds of
looking my sister's a real estate agent
she's sent me listings I think my
minimum is somewhere around 20 000
square feet that I've actually
considered but there's been a bunch of
different
options that have come up that we will
visit we'll visit a building and just
look around and be like all right what
can we build in here is this is this
floor layout like gonna be able to suit
us making studios in here making
podcasts in here there's a there's a
very Hefty content production
consideration so I don't know if there's
a number that actually will end up being
targeted but we sort of walk into the
building and we get a feel for it nice
yeah I remember when you moved into this
one and you were like doing the tour
showing it around it was it's just so
exciting and I think that's one thing
that your channel does really well where
I and probably the 50 million other
people who follow you feel like there's
in a way this relationship with you and
we get very excited oh my God you're
moving to a new studio that's really
cool and you're like showing us around
and it's just it's just a great Vibe I
often worry when I'm 55 years old am I
still going to be being like what's up
guys welcome back to the channel YouTube
video YouTube video about personal
development do you ever worry like what
are you going to be doing when you're
like 55 years old that's sort of
existential question yeah I guess not
you know I there is a uh there is a sort
of a larger life cycle of
media formats that is fascinating to me
where a lot of people who have been
around long enough kind of see this
generation of tech video creators on
YouTube as like a follow-up to the
newspaper columnists that they used to
follow for like the the Walton mossbergs
and David Pogues of the New York Times
and Wall Street journals
and I don't think those 50 60 70 year
olds are too mad that they're still
making Tech content it's just not the
new wave of Whatever video stuff that we
do now
and so I see the videos that we're
making now as being this larger wave and
I do wonder what comes after that I
don't know I don't I keep an eye out for
it I I'm not really sure
is Tick Tock a new wave or is it just a
smaller Crest on the top of the wave I
don't know it's hard to know in because
I couldn't have told you five years ago
what we'd be doing now so 50 years
I don't know but
um I do think about yeah that that wave
of like I enjoy Tech I enjoy making
content about and with the tech maybe
that looks different when I'm 40 or 50.
but I have no idea how it looks I go
glimpses of your view into this and
you're calling into your interview
um but how how are you thinking about
short form content like shorts and reels
and tick tocks and I know you've got the
MKBHD shorts Channel where some of the
stuff on that has been cool but for
example if again if you wanted to you
could 10x your output on short short
form content to think and you could be
thinking hey Tick Tock is where all the
kids are at let's just bang out the
content on Tick Tock but it seems like
you're not going down that approach so
yeah how do you how do you think about
tick-tocky type content yeah okay so
that last point you made is really very
close to how I think about it is like
the uh the demographics of our audience
so again uh I'm 28 a lot of my audience
is right from I'm about
14 to 35 let's say just like 15 years
less to maybe 15 years older just
somewhere on there and endlessly
probably undefeated with creators what
I'll see is as they get older their
younger audience that was closer to
their previous age becomes less
interested and I guess their older
audience becomes more interested so when
I see Tick Tock I'm like that's where
the youngest parts of my audience will
inevitably be if I want to talk to those
people and anyone using Tupac that
doesn't mean you're a child that just
means like that's the average of what a
tick tock scroller is doing if I want to
reach that younger audience I guess I
should be on Tick Tock but is that my
goal or am I really just concerned with
reaching the same people who are making
a purchase decision who who have some
disposable income who have a choice to
make about what piece of tech to buy and
maybe the age of those people isn't
going to change I mean it's cool to get
kids into Tech I still think that's
awesome and I think there is probably a
cool way that we can make short form
content that is interesting to younger
audiences and maybe that's a net
positive because we can get people
interested in Tech and that's cool but I
think the Target demographic is actually
the same age as it's always been whether
it's shorts or longer videos or podcasts
or anything like that
um
so it sounds like you don't feel that
pressure of like like I've spoken to a
bunch of other creators who and myself
included who sort of feel that pressure
of ah crap Tick Tock is where where all
the new people are everyone shows that
like maybe YouTube is on the decline am
I gonna stay relevant by uh am I going
to try and force myself to stay relevant
by kind of adapting and becoming a tick
tocker as well yeah okay so that's a
different question so relevant if my
goal was just to be famous which I don't
want then I would be all in on Tick Tock
right but here's a different way of
thinking about it when I'm going to
search for the new iPhone comes out
where do I go look for that video I go
to youtube.com and I type in the YouTube
search box that is where I want to live
for those people who are searching for
that information if that answer ever
changes if it's like the new phone came
out let me go into Tick Tock and see
what people are saying about the phone
then I guess that is when I'll feel that
pressure but I think for the people who
feel the pressure to be relevant or the
pressure for the eyeballs or the fame or
something like that then you'll feel the
pressure because Tick Tock is a hundred
percent accomplishing that now the most
viewed piece of content I have ever made
in 15 years is a 12 second Tick Tock of
me unfolding the LG wing it has 35
million views if I wanted the eyeballs
I'd be all over Tick Tock but I think
it's different it's just that people
searching for things the people making
purchase decisions I'm trying to make
valuable content for them and so that's
still YouTube so that's why I'm thinking
of it I'm just out of out of curiosity
if you were to look at your analytics do
you find that most of your growth comes
from search or is it mostly through like
home page suggested the browsy type
features growth interestingly comes from
the brows and suggested
um but I still feel that like slightly
intangible like section of it's almost
like time based when I when you look at
a comment section of a video like the
first three to four or five hours of
people commenting on video are not
people who came from search there are
people who subscribed who found it with
browse then like a week or two later
there's people who are searching on the
subject and then watching the video and
then commenting and that's a whole new
separate crowd that might not be the
YouTube growth you're after but you can
still see the value in that so we sort
of optimize the content for both of
those groups of people but they're very
different times
so do you then change titles like you
wouldn't believe this phone versus a
Google pixel 6A review and I kind of
know the answer to this because I I
don't see you doing those sort of browse
type clickbaity type titles particularly
yeah I I see those titles and it comes
down to again like what what I want to
watch what would I click on what would I
want to subscribe to and sometimes I do
see this title and thumbnail which is
just like because you know you're doing
the analytics you're like oh I have to
have a face and a thumbnail I'm gonna
have a sort of a clickbaity blurred out
object you wouldn't believe this oh
check it out I I don't click those I
don't watch those videos if I was
thinking wow every time I click one of
those I am very happy with what I
watched then I would probably explore
formatting my content like that but I
think if you just name it what it is
you can't lose right that's it you're
gonna get what you came for yeah there's
no way you're let down I told you
exactly what you were getting into we we
play with like the the post text
formatting a little bit sometimes play
with a little pun at the end of the
title but you know what you're getting
yeah yeah I was having this debate with
myself
um just yesterday when I was filming
some stuff where I was thinking you know
this is a video about how to start an
email newsletter and then I was thinking
oh but like do we know if people want to
start an email newsletter I know it's
something I want to teach but what if I
said called it something like this thing
that you're not doing is a thing you
should be doing question mark or you
know something something like that to
get more eyeballs on it and I you know
it was a bit of a bit of a debate I was
having one myself right like I know a
lot of YouTubers who go down that route
and I've gone down that route in the
past but I was thinking you know what if
I didn't if if I was acting in a way
that I didn't need to worry about the
views and I didn't need to worry about
money what would I title the video it
would be called how to start a
newsletter or how to start a newsletter
that changes your life that you have a
little bit of clickbait yeah
um it wouldn't be called you wouldn't
believe this one thing that I did that
made me a millionaire or whatever the
hell else the the title might be and I
opted for the more vanilla title rather
than the more clickbaity one and I I
felt good about the decision but I guess
we'll we'll see on the analytics what
that looks like I also feel like
whenever I see those titles I'm like you
you are you are making the conscious
decision to weight your your
optimization more for the subscribers
and the browse feature and the search
the people searching for how to start a
newsletter will never find that video
even if that's exactly what we talk
about in the video if the title is
something completely different and the
thumbnail is something completely
different in clickbaity when I search
because I am specifically looking for
how to do this thing I search YouTube
how to start email newsletter if that
video comes up I'm not clicking it
because that's not looking like what I
want to watch the one right under it
that says how to start an email
newsletter I'm watching that one so if
you're trying to deliver value to a
certain type of person you have to
realize there's several buckets of
getting that that click
um you mentioned just now that you're
not particularly interested in being
famous and yet you are one of the most
famous Tech YouTubers OR tech people in
the world I would say uh what is your
relationship with Fame broadly uh I
think I'm lucky that most people who
watch Tech videos are at home most of
the time it's great so I can go out and
I'm you know I do it's cool that there
are people in public that recognize my
videos and my work which is which is
very awesome I I happily talk to people
you know it's funny the other day
yesterday I was walking out to my car
and the UPS guy
pulled up as he was delivering to the
building and stopped and said hey I just
watched a video on the pixel 6A and I
just had a question about this feature
and just went right into like the
features of the phone that I just
reviewed and I was like that's
that's someone who really pays attention
to the videos that's amazing that's
probably my ideal interaction it's fun
we actually get to talk about tech and
there's a lot of YouTubers who are
famous for them and they can't go
outside because people just want to talk
to them I also have another hilarious
anecdote if we have time for it which is
uh the the YouTube Creator Summit every
year I think there's a couple but
basically it's a you know a hundred or
so creators from a certain region in my
case North America all going to a
certain hotel somewhere and meeting
together but also meeting with the CEO
of YouTube and a bunch of Executives at
YouTube and just talking about how we
feel about the platform things like that
inevitably they they put us all up in
the hotel and they give us this little
postcard that says like hey you know
let's be considerate and not post about
this on social media because if your
fans find out where we are
you know how they are they might show up
it's a hotel it's public information so
we try not to make it public where we
are when there's a hundred of the
biggest creators in the same building
but inevitably someone posts on
Instagram and someone looks in the
background and sees the name of the
hotel and suddenly there's a hundred
screaming little girls outside and we're
like what what happened somebody told us
that was great and I remember this
happened and I was standing at the at
the door of the hotel and there's like
two or 300 like teenage girls just like
waiting for I think it was Lele pons or
something just like I can't wait oh my
God they're screaming like let us in we
want to see this and I was waiting for
my Uber to go back home
my Uber pulled up in the street behind
them and I walked out the building and I
just walked straight through the middle
of them and not a single one of them
even noticed who I was I just walked
right through walked got in the Uber and
I was like this is great any anybody who
would have been into Tech like they're
at home maybe they show up at a tech
event that's cool we can chat there but
like
I'm not here to try to be like screaming
girl outside the hotel famous that's
we're not it's fine they can have that
that's great do you get much hate as a
tech YouTuber I've never seen any in
your comments but I mean 50 million subs
and like millions of views in every
video you you must do what sort of hate
do you get if any and like how how do
you deal with it hate is funny because
it's formatted as just like trying to
get your attention uh which is pretty
funny sometimes so I I do think there's
a good amount of like legitimate
feedback people who watch a video and
genuinely believe you know something's
wrong about the video that they would
have done it differently that it should
have been a different way and you can
read a comment and feel and understand
that this person really means what
they're saying and then there's hate
that's just like ah this guy sucks ah
this guy loves Apple oh he can't stop
talking about how much he hates this
company oh he's biased oh Samsung paid
him whatever I don't pay any attention
to any of those comments because they're
just unfounded and they mean nothing and
also their wrong so fine so I try to
separate those buckets in my head yes I
do get hate and I try to sift through to
find the the grain of Truth inside of
every
pearl of hate there's something in there
that maybe I can learn from one of the
sort of genre of I guess hate but like I
kind of don't like what hate because it
sort of implies malicious intense
sometimes but one of the genres of sort
of uh feedback comments that
that I find sort of strikes me at the
core is when someone will say something
like hey Ellie your videos used to be
good back when you were back when back
when you were a doctor and you were
providing value to society I actually
watched your videos because you were
actually doing something interesting now
you're just a YouTuber who makes videos
for the sake of making videos and I'm
like oh man it's kind of true I'm a
YouTuber
like I'm not a doctor anymore and like
uh there's always be a part of me that's
gonna be lying awake at night thinking
about that do you get that response to
any sort of genre of hey comments or
negative comments or anything or are you
sufficiently Zen that you're just like
ah it's either feedback or it's
unfounded no I don't think I've seen
that too much I mean I think of when you
just mentioned that I just thought of
Mark Rober who used to work at Apple
used to work at NASA's jet propulsion
lab and now is a full-time Video Creator
and does amazing videos and amazing work
for getting kids interested in stem so I
don't see the problem with being a
YouTuber maybe that person's kind of old
yeah yeah
no problem
what was the the thought process or like
the strategy or like the reason behind
starting the waveform podcast and how
has that kind of evolved over time yeah
the podcast was uh started for two
reasons one because we had all these
conversations in the studio that we
realized were very interesting or
insightful and we were like we could
have recorded that that would have
actually been a really interesting
conversation to get other people's
opinions on and two uh is because the
videos that we produce are so produced
they're polished and they're they're
structured in a way that the podcast
allows us to just like sit back with a
mic and just talk and if something
interesting happens or some conversation
comes up then
then it's more casual and that's a sort
of a different way of creating content
but it's actually fun for me to just
like think off the top of my head about
this new phone you know I just had a
thought about this I as we were talking
I realized just Dive Right In that sort
of thing so it's been pretty successful
for both of those outlets for us and we
look to keep keep doing it so do you
have like a schedule where you're
thinking about episode episodic content
and like what your talking points for
the week are or is it literally just hey
I've got a cool thought David let's go
chat about it on the Pod and you go over
to the studio and turn the cameras on
yeah it's it's somewhere in between that
we'll have um we know we make one
episode per week and we record sometime
on Wednesday every Wednesday
um and so we might have like a a
conversation on Tuesday and we're like
hey wait save that thought write it down
let's talk about it on the Pod like
we'll have that and so we'll sort of
gather everything from the week we have
a slack Channel literally just called
waveform and we'll just dump thoughts in
there and then every Tuesday or
Wednesday we'll just like drag things
out of there like oh we were talking
about this before let's talk about this
oh remember this this tweet we saw or
this random announcement of a thing what
did you think about that and we'll just
get into it so it is probably the most
structured like format wise that we have
because it's like literally one upload
per week but that's kind of how it goes
that's a good idea like I often think
that with our team where and we you know
we even hired a full-time videographer
just to sort of capture this but it
ended up not being with audio and miking
people up that we always have really
interesting conversations in the studio
about like being a Creator and like the
business side of things and stuff and
some subset of our audience really is
interested in that kind of stuff and
it's still a part of me that's like oh I
really wish we had for example a podcast
Studio that was always set up so we
could literally just sit down and hit
record because right now it just feels
like a lot of friction and then there's
all these interesting conversations
happening which are not really relevant
to our content but are just interesting
and we want to kind of share them
somehow uh any any thoughts on that you
think it's nice having like a set of a
studio that's set up at all times yeah
that's this is the most TurnKey room in
the whole studio we walk in I hit that
light I hit that light hit that light
over there the board turns on and we're
ready to go so if there's like a thought
we have or like a guest or someone Pops
in we're like hey you wanna you wanna
just talk about that on this on the
podcast real quick and we can we can
just do it that frictionless experience
is is part of our ideal production
environment so yeah that's that's pretty
key nice all right I'm sold we're gonna
get a some kind of podcast room in our
in our new studio whatever whatever that
looks like hot mics everywhere oh
absolutely absolutely
um
similar question around the the studio
Channel what's what's going on there
what was the idea behind it and
why did you decide that like oh it would
be cool to sort of showcase the team
rather than it sort of being I guess you
being the the centerpiece at all times
yeah it's uh so the studio channel is
really I guess the the studio itself is
the main character like you you watch
the videos and you feel like you are in
the studio you feel like you're almost
part of the team
and that that's that's the idea is like
we realize we have such a cool unique
experience here at the studio that like
let's share it let's at least give
people an opportunity to like peek in
and get a window into it because there's
there's a lot of fun stuff here and then
we'll have random ideas of like you know
be funny a parody video about this
commercial that was super bad or you
know what else would be funny if we did
like a chopped episode but like with
making YouTube videos instead of food so
yeah we just we just have crazy fun
ideas and we do them and I think the
idea is you feel like you are in the
studio and that's that's a pretty easy
thing to accomplish yeah it creates a
very sort of fly on the wall kind of
vibe um
I really enjoyed like the Leica M11
review for example where I was like oh
this is a cool camera I wonder if Mark
has gone that's kind of weird for MKBHD
to to do a video reviewing that
particular camera but I was sick there's
an episode of the studio where the team
are reviewing the camera uh which was
which is pretty awesome so the studio
channel is it purely for fun or is there
more of a strategic business objective
behind it kind of to use that
terminology it is definitely for fun but
I think it's also interesting and
experimental to have a channel that
doesn't depend entirely on me being on
camera and so in that sense there's a
little bit of the the pressure on the
ideas to be interesting there because
it's not just product focused stuff it's
more ideas but it is interesting that we
actually have successfully created a
channel where I can appear in videos
sometimes or sometimes there's entire
agency where someone's just like I gotta
review this keyboard like people need to
know what I think about this keyboard
and they have an outlet to do that so
that's pretty fun
um yeah sort of a combination of the two
and like on that note of like this a big
part of this business like all almost
all parts of the business seem to
revolve around you as an individual one
thing that a lot of other creators that
I know have done is slowly try and build
their own Brands and build their own
teams into their own setups
in a way that means that the business
Will Survive even if the Creator decides
suddenly that ah you know I'm not really
feeling it or I want to take a break for
a whole year do you think about that
sort of dissociating yourself from the
business so the business can survive
without you or are you fairly chill
about just continuing to be the sort of
centerpiece of I guess the nucleus of
the whole business yeah this is probably
the number one biggest cardinal sin as a
business major that I've committed which
is I am totally fine being the one that
is necessary for everything for the
engine to run for at least the main
channel on the podcast like I guess
theoretically the podcast could be other
conversations and I couldn't I might not
be there but
yeah I I think I'm pretty happy uh with
being The Taste maker for the operation
and so that that means I'm involved with
pretty much every part of the process
and if I did want to take a break for a
year then it would absolutely fall off
face the Earth and that's on me and
you're okay with that in theory or do
you just imagine take a break for a year
that's that's basically what it is I'm
okay with that be so okay I'm fine with
that because I know it's very unlikely
I'm going to take a break for longer
than about a week or two which in
YouTube terms is nothing and then also
um we do think strategically about
larger brand collaborations and larger
product opportunities and things that we
could make and we have been having those
conversations behind the scenes for like
the better part of the last five years
and it's really just about finding the
right thing I've had endless
opportunities to just jump right in and
be a part of something that seems pretty
cool but
um the list of things that gets me
really excited about it and really
wanting to like make that a priority is
very small
so yeah those conversations bubble up
now and again we have our agency that
that works on those sorts of deals but
yeah it's uh it's mostly just a nucleus
type of deal oh interesting yeah I feel
like I'm I'm in that place right now
where it's like oh obviously the entire
business has reliant on me and we've
sort of made a few inroads in the past
of like oh let's try and diversify etc
etc what if Ali gets hit by a bus then
all of a sudden the business dies and
now that we have employees and stuff
I think in the past I was like oh my God
this is a big concern we need to sort
this out but actually
instead of what I've seen over the last
few months is that like if someone has
worked for our business and then strikes
off on their own to do freelance stuff
they're going to get clients no problem
like they're going to have zero issues
and so I imagine it's the same with your
team do you do you worry about like oh
crap how am I going to support the team
or is it is it a similar kind of
attitude I think it's pretty similar
yeah the the team is supported I mean
the the work that they that they create
adds so much value that like everything
is everything is set like they they make
the the I guess if it's a machine with a
bunch of Gears like they are all the
gears are really important the machine
doesn't work with gears missing but like
you kind of have to have all of them for
it to be operational so everybody has a
stake in everything I think
so yeah
um final couple of things I wanted to
talk to you about is I so I I've
recently started dabbling with Angel
Investing in startups and I can't
remember which one it was that I
recently invested in but it seemed like
you and Casey were also on the cap table
um I wanted to ask like how how long
have you been doing Angel Investing or
what how what what's your take like what
how did you get started like what's the
sort of companies you invest in and like
how does how does that work kind of from
from your end if you're open to talking
about right yeah yeah it's pretty new to
me so it's definitely within the past
like two years that I've started like
seeing investment opportunities and it
is very much I've watched so much Shark
Tank that to me it's like I see a pitch
and immediately I go into shark mode if
it's like well what if a big company
copies this well what if this like I
there are there are a couple ideas that
are really cool and I've I've invested
in I think four companies total in the
last couple years so it's not very many
but it's the companies whose products I
believe in and who I think I can add
value to and and maybe it can become
something bigger that's the general idea
um so I guess yeah it's not that many
but it is it is really interesting now
being able to behind the scenes instead
of in front of the scenes have a sort of
an influence or an impact on something
you think can be bigger than it is
sick yeah I've I think I've kind of over
stretched on that front where I've just
sort of saying yes to any opportunity
that came my way and now it's a bit like
oh I'm getting WhatsApp messages from
these companies I've invested in and I
feel really bad because I suck at
replying to WhatsApp messages for my
friends let alone kind of people like
I've given money to and I might have to
kind of put a bit of a pause on it maybe
like four four feels like a manageable
amount I guess final thing I want to ask
you about is uh firstly thank you so
much for being so open and gracious and
stuff with with your time this has been
a wonderful conversation what sort of
goals do you have in or sort of what are
the things you're thinking about in your
personal life so like the non-youtube
non non-work stuff do you have any sort
of personal goals that you're I guess
working towards
um how are you thinking about that yeah
I mean I definitely have a a second half
of my brain that's Switched Off when I'm
at the studio which is during weekdays
we we make the tech stuff we do this the
studio video thing I also play on some
Ultimate Frisbee teams and we have big
goals for those teams every year we have
pretty lofty goals I am leaving for a
week starting tomorrow to go compete at
the club World Championships which is a
pretty lofty goal I mean that's that's
going to take a lot of focus and I won't
be making videos for a week so it's
stuff like that I feel like the left
brain right brain thing is pretty real
work hard play hard you've heard the the
phrases so yeah a little bit of that a
little bit of uh keeping my competitive
side entertained versus the creative
side all right well Marcus this has been
an absolutely wonderful conversation
thank you so much we'll put links to all
the stuff in the video description below
where can people go to learn more about
you and to kind of see what you're up to
uh any if you just search MKBHD on any
platform probably video platform you'll
probably find me yeah amazing right
thank you so much for taking the time
this has been wonderful and hopefully we
can meet IRL if I ever get a visa to
come over to New Jersey sometime I'm I'm
currently working on it
open invite to the studio feel free to
come by anytime this is fun that would
be awesome all right thank you so much
man take care have a great day say hi to
the team and we'll we'll see you guys
later bye-bye all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye